alternatives to firefighting foams are
sought by fire experts all over the
world including here at Germany's
biggest airport in frankfurt in Venus on
the film-forming firms are crucial in
fighting flammable liquids like gasoline
heating or kerosene and so forth they
are the strongest weapon firefighters
have but today's firms all contain PFT's
so after we put out a fire we have to
bring in an excavator and remove the
soil we need a real alternative to
existing phones without these toxic
materials but that extinguished just as
well to test one such alternative
chemists from the University of Cologne
are here in Frankfort today they've
spent years developing a foam entirely
free of pfts but they don't yet know
whether it will put out fires as
thoroughly and quickly as firefighters
require a handheld fire extinguisher and
five litres of kerosene are the
materials in the experiment unfertile
mutton it's not so easy to test a fire
you can't set up a fire experiment just
anywhere so we're grateful for frankfurt
airports cooperation will be getting
feedback from the people who will
ultimately be using this new phone one
spark is enough to set the kerosene on
fire temperatures of 800 to 1,000
degrees Celsius are quickly reached the
fire can only be extinguished by keeping
oxygen from the burning fluid and that
requires a solid foam carpet the
chemists from cologne long sought
alternatives that could replace
perfluoro octane sulfonate or PFOS this
ten side produces the best fire
extinguishing foam so far but it also
causes the worst environmental damage
this yet but so far we only know about
two classes of substances with these
qualities first the poly fluorinated ten
sides which would like to replace for
environmental reasons and then there are
siloxane switch we used here in our new
fire extinguishing firms
but so far we haven't been able to
produce siloxane that have the qualities
we need for extinguishing fires we had
to synthesize and test completely new
molecules in this class of substances
fire extinguishing foams containing pfos
s have been banned since 2011 but the
substances that have replaced them don't
work as well and they still contain
fluorine and damage the environment the
siloxane ten sites developed in Cologne
are based on renewable resources and are
completely free of fluorine the
researchers have tested 400 new
substances of this kind for their
suitability in fighting fires the ten
sites have to rapidly spread across a
liquid surface on their own forming a
layer that is as airtight as possible
that's the only way the foam can cut off
the fire from its oxygen supply most big
fires cannot be controlled without foams
that create a film of water the siloxane
ten sides work in the lab now they have
to be tested in practice
that testing is being done at Frankfurt
Airport with a simple handheld fire
extinguisher filled with the new foam
the results look good
i'm at the cooktop we wanted to see if
the foam forms a water film and it does
but we had hoped it would cover the
whole surface better the drainage rate
is not high enough but this was very
good for a first attempt if the layer of
foam were thicker it would close up
better too we hope this gap would close
on its own that would have been optimal
Marga Viva where'd you meet them the
Cologne chemists and the firefighters at
the airport think they're on the right
track after more testing their
environmentally friendly firefighting
foam could be in use by 2017 until then
foams containing flooring will still be
the big guns when fighting fires and
they'll still cause severe environmental
damage that's expensive to clean up all
over the world firefighters are waiting
for the new foams from cologne